هناك الكثير من الأشياء التي يجب على دبي أن
تقدمها لأي شخص لديه اهتمام أو
رياضة يريد أن ينموها ، اسمي
تيموثي يان
، لقد عشت في دبي على مدار الـ
18 عامًا الماضية ، وقد أتاح لي العيش في دبي
الإعجاب باستكشاف مختلف التطرف  الرياضة
لأن هذا هو ما أنا في الفأرة
التي تكتشف أن هناك الكثير من
الجبال والأبيض كما هو الحال في
جبال هازارد
[موسيقى]
حتا هو جانب مختلف تمامًا من دبي ،
فهو على بعد 130 كيلومترًا فقط ، وهناك
أنواع مختلفة من الأنشطة التي
يمكنك القيام
بذلك
عندما أهرب من المدينة
[موسيقى]
عندما أذهب إلى الشريط ، تشعر
بالراحة حقًا وتركز فقط على
رفاهيتك ، لقد كنت في جبلين
في الماضي  أربع سنوات حتى الآن لقد تسلقت
حول العالم ستة عشر جبلًا
أستمتع حقًا بذلك وأحب العثور على
مسارات جديدة واكتشاف ما هو هناك ،
أعتقد حقًا أننا بحاجة إلى الطاقة التي
نحصل عليها كبشر من الهواء الطلق
نحن في ذرة ساخنة الآن حيث  بيو  تعال إلى
هنا للتجديف بالكاياك ، إنه مكان
مثالي للتواجد بالخارج للحصول على بعض الهدوء في
الماء بين الجبال ، سيكون
جميلًا ،
دعنا نذهب
بمجرد وصولك إلى السد ، الماء
يتجمد ، إنه طبيعي تمامًا
من المطر الذي ينتهي بك الأمر إلى رؤية
أنواع مختلفة من  الحياة البرية لمدة ثلاث ليالٍ للخروج
هنا خارج المدينة مباشرةً ، وعند القدوم
إلى هذا المكان الجميل ، يمكنك بالفعل
بناء شغف هنا نظرًا
لعدد الخيارات التي لديك فيما يتعلق
بالأنشطة لتجربة التواصل مع
الطبيعة ، مما يساعدنا على البقاء إيجابيين
ونتطلع إلى  ما يجب فعله بعد ذلك بالإضافة إلى
أن تحدي أنفسنا مهم جدًا لأنفسنا
[موسيقى]
أنت